electing coke was the champion of
Siberia before he made hundreds of
millions selling Russians dumplings beer
and credit cards
he's now pumping his money and energy
and do his very own team that has a
passion ton business and wants to talk
to me about it well he does a little
writing of his own
so what extent is this about making
money and to what extent is this you're
a rich guy you can afford to have a team
you know it's a little bit of a toy so I
would rather spend money this way then
to lose them in casino oh really
prostitutes always stupidly up we're a
week into the tour of Switzerland with
one of the best teams in the business
and we've got full access but for the
riders it's just another day on the road
a chance to put their weary feet up and
rest their legs average Pro will cover
30,000 kilometers a year and there's
just a couple hours before today's
punishing 219 kilometer race to the top
of a swiss mountain today it's just
before the race and it's time to talk
strategy often lasting you you have to
be all that on rhoma Irama is to take it
the last climb in position Ali
200 kilometers ahead of them high in the
Alps team owner Tim Cove is himself
attacking the finish line rides at least
part of nearly every race business or
cycling it Co flex to win back at the
bus tink off checks in with the team
they're in second place looking for
dangerous battle money that line the
riders are on the final stretch or not
the only one suffering King Cove rushes
to find a TV for the finish come on you
can do that we have to finish the job
yeah it was second the team finishes
three seconds behind the winner are you
happy I'm not because I won't add it all
in cycling there is no second place
Armstrong won seven Tour de France's
nobody remember who was second if I
wanted to win not the decider election
Co is one of the most competitive driven
people I've ever come across
I make money I I sponsor the Peschel of
my life
rising from humble beginnings to become
one of Russia's most successful serial
entrepreneurs with a bank on the stock
exchange the eight years he spent
suffering as a pro rider was a good
start I would never be so successful if
I would redo the cycling from the youth
because that's what that'll teach me to
win to be the winner to fight through
the blood and then eventually didn't do
it yeah jeah
TCF and see the electrical is the man he
is number one
Brian Chilcote Bloomberg in the Swiss
Alps